right now all of our eggs are in one
basket and the baskets called earth we
can't stay in this solar system forever
it's just a fact so if we if we do stay
here we would essentially you know the
Sun would essentially engulf the inner
planets and even if we've achieved
perfect world peace and there's no
hunger there's no poverty there's no
disease it'll all be gone if we're still
here so some of the first missions to
Mars obviously we have multiple
satellites already in orbit and so some
of the first missions are really planned
for within the next 15 years
but there are active and long-term plans
in NASA to have people you know colonies
there living there whether it's either
asteroids moons or potentially Mars
you know the timeline goes up to two or
three hundred years out is when we've
started to begin some of that work of
actually not just sending exploratory
missions but people are Chua living
there and I think this is not only sort
of what is the natural next step of
really human evolution and exploration
but I would even argue is our duty as a
species because we're the only species
that has an awareness of extinction that
so I think it gives us the
responsibility to preserve not only our
species but actually all species but if
you keep going further out eventually go
to Mars you go to other solar systems
it's really uh the question just begs
the question back on itself is like well
you can't keep going and going going at
the end of the time eventually the
universe Alleva keep expanding and so it
will be too far apart or it may collapse
back in on itself and so I think there
are the last question of my long term
plan for the laboratory is which of
course will all be long dead for but is
is do we prevent the universe from
collapsing back on itself in the hopes
that life will arise anew or do we
actually use our ingenuity and
technological acumen to prevent the
universe from collapsing and at that
point maybe we'll be controlling gravity
I think we would have to probably
prevent it and maybe carve out a small
area of the universe that wouldn't
collapse or would somehow survive which
we have no idea how that's going to
happen but I think the ethical question
we can think about today is how much
into what degree do we literally alter
the universe to preserve ourselves and I
think life and gravity are the only two
things that prevent expansion of matter
in the universe and so I think and sort
of decrease entropy and so I think we
have a responsibility to try and maybe
keep ourselves alive so I think not only
maybe should we keep ourselves alive
even at the end of
universe but that we may we may have you
know no choice because I think that's
what we usually do as a species